I'm very interested in what the internet
thinks your net worth is oh can we look
that up it says you've got 13 million
why I find this particularly fascinating
because the business model of ICP your
pioneers of your own like guerrilla
marketing you own your own label right
so you own your own publishing I mean
this has been the way it's been since we
made our first dollar all the money we
make goes back into the company and when
we started making more and more money it
pretty much stayed like that even into
our Platinum success we were like that
stuff but I don't have 13 I
don't even have a I mean I of course I
have a bank account I don't have a
million in it no I don't even got 500
000 in it or a hundred thousand I'll
keep it real in my personal account I
don't even have a hundred thousand
because everything is in psychopathy
yeah still that's both me and Joey's
company